with the new Intel Raptor lick
processors entering the market users can
expect highly clocked high power
processors that deliver incredible
performance be it for professional
Endeavors productive workloads or gaming
as the upcoming big hit this from The
Blue Team in 2023 they're just as good
if not better than the AMD Alternatives
in most cases as we found out here at
the geek Labs we've tested a wide
variety of laptops and many of them are
very good but you can't buy them all
right what separates the best laptops
from good laptops is how they Balance
power efficiency portability and comfort
and today do we have a laptop for you
guys enter the MSI stealth 14 Studio
probably one of the coolest and sleekest
of laptops money can buy in 2023 it has
plenty of horsepower to create content
play games at the highest quality set
things and more importantly is light
enough to bring around comfortably so
let's take a dive into the cell 14
Studios features and see how it performs
in the box we have the cell l14 Studio
together with the charger any manual for
all the necessary information it is a 14
inch ultralight gaming laptop the one
that we have comes in Pure White there
is also a star blue but that's for the
stealth 16. this stealth 14 is 19
millimeters thin and I'd say it's low
profile design is pretty stealthy I mean
it's a name come on it weighs 1.7
kilograms thanks to its magnesium alloy
chassis making it light and durable
everything looks consistent and solidly
constructed and on top of that it's
fingerprint smudge proof it has a per
key RGB gaming keyboard by Steel series
or style points and extra large touchpad
more space means more control and to top
it off it has a nice gaming Edge to it
when used in the dark with RGB and its
logo glows and you know what they say
you game better with more RGB the MSI
stealth 14 studio is very compact for a
laptop that has powerful components
inside it's definitely no one trick pony
now for the next best thing besides the
performance it's display it has a 14
inch QHD Plus 25cm 60 by 1600 240 hertz
refresh rate DCI P3 IPS display that
offers a 16 by 10 aspect ratio aka the
golden ratio which makes it 10 longer
than a 16x9 display which also means you
get more real estate and room to work
with for watching videos movies gaming
editing videos the whole nine yards you
want ports oh MSI I set you up with some
ports you got a type c USB Thunderbolt
another type c USB 3.2 Gen 2 with PD
charging a type a USB 3.2 Gen 2 a HDMI
2.1 capable of 8K 60hz or 4K hunting
Hertz and a 3.5 millimeter mikin
headphone out combo Jack there are
definitely enough ports to get you
through whatever needs doing or for
something simple like connecting a mouse
and keyboard combo to make your workflow
even smoother of Smooth you're going to
be blasting across the internet Speedway
with Intel's killer ax Wi-Fi 6E that
promises blazing internet speeds not
forgetting stable Bluetooth 5.3 for all
your earbuds controllers and other
Bluetooth devices if you want to keep
your workspace tidy it's already great
so far and we haven't even got to the
main course under the hood this baby can
pack up to a 13th gen Intel Core i7 CPU
and this unit here rocks and Nvidia
GeForce RTX 4060 laptop GPU with 16 gigs
of ddr5 RAM with a clock speed of 5200
megahertz and you can upgrade it to a
maximum of 64 gigs of RAM you've got
power you've got speed in such a compact
package which makes it perfect for the
creative and gamer on the go whether
you're traveling or if you need to make
quick edits in the field with 4K footage
these stealth 14 Studio has your back
literally because it's so light we ran a
couple of benchmarks with returnal PC
Mark 3D Mark and we will be Flash
watching all the results right here and
I have to say the stealth 14 works
impressively with any heavy load thrown
its way but of course have it plugged in
to get the best performance out of it
also you've got space for these space
for days space for days with a one
terabyte m.2 mbme SSD PCI gen 4x4 for
all the files you need for your projects
and gaming with a heavy workload and
gaming comes a lot of heat and that's
not good thankfully the stealth 14 comes
equipped with two fans that may not
sound like a lot but they are two fans
that work in tandem with its dedicated
Vapor chamber cooler on the CPU and GPU
the larger heat capacity reduces the
noise and temperature which keeps
performance stable while on heavy
workloads of course you can't be
productive without banging some tunes
Dyno audio has designed the two speakers
on this laptop and there are also two
subwoofers so you got this you won't
lose any quality when you're blasting
the speakers just don't blast them for
too long and the speakers audio is crisp
warm and having those soft office there
gives you quite the auditory experience
whether you're gaming listening to music
or watching a movie the stealth 14 runs
only a 72 watt hour battery this is a
great capacity if you're again working
on a flight somewhere or if you want to
get some work done at the cafe it does
have a long run time but it's relative
to how heavy your workout is of course
if you need more juice you can hook up
with Stony 40 watt power adapter and it
will run amazing ER that's all right
better I mean and yeah that's that's
everything the MSI style 14 studio is a
great companion for you content creators
Gamers and even students out there this
laptop sits right between high-end power
and more affordable mid-range machines
all that said the MSI style 14 studio is
one of the better gaming laptops you can
buy with the highest spec model offering
a competitive price among the premium
laptop Market it's definitely a laptop
worth considering so that's it for this
video we hope you enjoyed it let us know
what you think about the MSI cell phone
in studio and if you have any questions
leave them in the comments and we'll do
our best to get to them until next time
[Music]
foreign